hợp đầu tiên và vẫn đánh dân sần chứng là thầy đến mà chị ở cái cửa hàng đầu tiên của FT và chị làm cái bán hàng giới nhất.
Các anh nghĩ mũ chỉ làm cửa hàng đứng thì tới nhiên, người có cái gì mà trong người mình nói bị trổi vậy,
trước giờ các bạn khác làm chị không hoang tâm tạm bị chị chị là trong mình chị thôi.
Chỉ mà mày giờ nó phải là số khu cả, có thể các bạn nghĩa với những là ăn uống trong cửa hàng,
sự nhiên chỉ cảm thấy là cái gì đó nó, nó không có chính trục.
Và khi chị có chịu những việc đó thì chị nghĩa là cái gì sao khác?
Tại vì trong đầu nó cũng nghĩa là tuo bác ngựa là đánh thằng có miếng này.
Là đảy cho các hàng người ta ở quay lại người ta mua hàng nhiều hơn.
Còn sau đó cói nằm ăn được thứ, rất là trong đầu mình cứ nghĩ là mình là làm tuo người ta,
nhưng thực ra là người ta mà thấy cái tiền của nằm nào đâu.
Chuy ở, hồi người ta chỉ thấy cái chuyện là mình đang có chuyện với người ta thôi.
Chỉ em sao bắt đầu chị bất, có cái chuyện là có thể có chịu đấy.
Ngồi xuống chị nói chị họp lại, để mua hàng thành ta nghiệp dài,
thì chị thì tình thử hảm ơn sẽ tổng lần như đây.
Đi là mình công khai, đó sống khuyên là có hảm ơn nói được làm được một tiêu tiền đang ngoài đúng.
Hãy là ngon ngon ngon đúng sau đó là thực ra.
Đi quên, đúng sẽ theo cái sẹp tỏa vô vô cast the first step, mới nhất.